Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, thank you for joining us, Ruffians, for our This is Now We're in the Territory of Fuwawa's Struggles with the Epics and Memories.
We're in our 102nd episode!
BAU BAU!
For a second there, I thought you were gonna forget who the hosts are.
Wow, Ruffians!
Don't forget who the hosts are.
But there might be some Ruffians who don't know who the hosts are.
Right!
So, for those who are joining us today for the very first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Hi!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
Huh?
Doesn't feel like it's been a while.
It has been a while.
It's been a while, huh?
It's been about two weeks, huh?
Two weeks?
It feels like it has been!
It's been 48 hours!
A.K.A.
two weeks.
BAU BAU!
We're so happy to be able to spend this morning together with you, Ruffians!
Because it's gonna be a very exciting day today!
It's gonna be an adventure, huh?
Yeah!
Moco-chan, let's see how today's day starts out.
Well... I hate to break it to you, but I... There's a Perroccino.
Moco-chan, you know how sometimes there's like really bad Pero Sightings?
And there's Pero Sightings where it's like, oh that's unfortunate.
Which one is it today?
Well, let's check!
De-den!
What?
Hi!
You're a baby!
Blondie!
Tiny little ears there!
Do you see?
I see.
Not Pero.
I see cat.
No.
No Pero.
Your body is so cute!
Right!
Orange cat!
But, but!
Body should not be making friends with Peron!
No.
No, he's nasty!
No!
No.
He might have said some nice things to us the other day.
But, he's no good, okay?
No good.
No.
He might eat your cat if you're not careful too, okay?
You wouldn't want that, right?
Right!
Would you rather have Pero eat your cat?
Or us?
Ruffians!
Which one?
Pero.
Or us?
Neither.
Are you sure about that?
Neither!
Please!
Neither?
No one?
This makes me want to eat blondie more.
Hi!
Blondie!
Only Fuwawa?
Yeah.
That's what I thought!
Well, you know, we're sure that blondie is super nice and cuddly and a cute cat, so you don't need to be making friends with someone like Pero.
Yeah, maybe, maybe get that car up and running and then take him to a pet shop.
Pet shop!
Yeah.
There should be lots of other cats he can become friends with.
Right.
Blondie's not in trouble.
Yeah.
Forget Pero, okay?
Forget him.
Yeah, go have a fun time with your little doofus, okay?
A doofus?
Yeah.
Doofus.
Little orange doofus.
BAU BAU!
It's been a very busy week for FUWAMOCO, but today!
Today, we got through a rough day today.
A rough day at the end of a very, very busy week.
Ruffians.
BAU BAU.
It really started off on the wrong paw for us.
Yeah.
You know, Fuwawa was running behind like crazy.
She's just running behind a bit, but like crazy this time.
And was just getting dressed about 10 minutes before we had to be out the door.
I was running around trying to find all my clothes.
I couldn't find them, Ruffians!
And then,
I just made it in time though!
And then Moco-chan here!
I thought I had our umbrellas packed with me!
But they had me as Moco-chan taking them out of my bag!
I shouldn't think it was raining, even though you know from the very moment we woke up, it was raining!
I didn't take it out of the bag, okay?
It wasn't in there.
I didn't take them out.
It must have been you, Moco-chan!
They were just, they were on the floor.
They were always in my bag!
I'm the umbrella keeper, right?
I didn't take them out.
No, but... It wasn't just like raining raining.
It was pouring dogs and dogs outside, Ruffians.
Yeah.
And then we were also already running late.
So we just had to dash and hope we didn't get too rained on.
But... In the end, we did quite a bit.
And, you know... I had clothes.
White clothing.
It was a little embarrassing.
You know?
And then we were all frazzled because we thought we were gonna be late.
So then we told Mane-chan, Sorry we're gonna be late!
I'm so sorry!
And then... We showed up right on time.
Which then caught Mane-chan a bit off guard.
Right?
Mane-chan, she was like, FUWAMOCO, you said you're gonna be late!
You know, we're always early!
You know, if we're not early then we start to panic a bit.
Why?
Why did I even bother?
I should just go back home!
I should just go home if I'm very late!
Yeah.
And, to top it off, I had a really pounding headache.
So then, Fuwawa had to explain things to me and Dog because I wasn't understanding things anymore.
BAU BAU BAU BAU.
Yeah.
You know, I think Maritel could tell that we're very off on the road.
But... But!
The good news is that we got to the next place we had to be at early!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Although, Fuwawa then tried to leave the building we were in through an entrance into another business's office there.
I don't know.
It's just... I was ready to go home, Ruffians.
You'll just go into another business!
That was the door in front of me, so... I don't know how you thought that was the exit!
It looked like an exit.
I don't know.
I'm glad Moco-chan you're with me, though.
We were supposed to go up a staircase.
I forgot that part.
Sometimes it's good to have a twin sister, Ruffians.
Now, we know FUWAMOCO's day started off on the wrong paw, but it ended up being on the right one!
So that means Ruffians, it's going to continue on the right paw for you!
No matter how unlucky or maybe rough it's going for you, we know that it'll be all okay!
Because FUWAMOCO!
On top of that, a very exciting weekend is waiting for all of us Ruffians!
So hang in there!
BAU BAU!
Do your best, okay, Ruffians?
As you know, Ruffians, recently we've been doing some trading in Minecraft.
A lot, a lot.
Can you say a lot?
FUWAMOCO Place.
Wait, what's a better word?
Doghouse.
Maybe that's a bit confusing with a real doghouse.
A cube.
FUWAMOCO Whole.
FUWAMOCO Hot.
Headquarters.
Dog Pound.
FUWAMOCO Shack.
I kind of like the FUWAMOCO Shack.
That sounds weird to me.
Tofu House.
Why?
Hideout.
A FUWAMOCO Hideout.
Oh, FUWAMOCO dog-jo.
What?
Like do-jo, but dog-jo.
I was very confused.
I'm beast.
Okay.
Hot!
Anyways.
I know.
What?
We had some good improvements, you know.
We had some sheep.
We got more sheep.
We made the sheep pink.
And we also got a cow!
And guess what we called him.
Shiori.
Yeah!
Shiori, he gives us a lot of milk, which we thought was a handy food, but it wasn't.
No!
It get rid of the poison, the curses.
Something we don't really need.
Yeah.
But we still love Shiori Lawrence, you know.
His first milk was a special one.
Yeah.
Do you think we can get more cows, Wolfy?
I think I got very lucky just helping to find the one cow.
Yes, his name is Shiori, okay?
Yeah.
Yeah, Moco-chan, you know, last time you had the first milk.
And the second milk.
I don't think I had any milk.
It's because I needed it though, because I had the poison.
Yeah, and then the second time we thought it was food, right?
It was a food.
But maybe we can get, we have Shiori 1 right now, right?
Then we can have Shiori 2, Shiori 3, Shiori 4.
Alright!
Maybe I can have the first milk of Shiori 4, Moco-chan?
Yeah.
I don't care, it's not useful.
But you know, we're slowly, slowly, slowly but surely, slowly but surely, starting to get the hang of Minecraft with eating food and digging and caves, so please help us to go into Minecraft pros, okay?
Milk is very important in Minecraft.
Not yet.
It doesn't do much.
We need food first.
We're dying.
Sharing food.
Sometimes.
But you know, if Final Senpai is a level 10 Minecrafter, we like to aim to be level 4.
Maybe one day, level 4.
Around there.
BAU BAU!
I want the chickens.
I want chickens.
More than Shiori too.
We need the compass.
Are there chickens?
Kairai's level 100.
Level 20 Kairai.
If we get chickens... Are there crows in Minecraft?
I need to know this to properly name the chickens.
Chickens.
Back then.
Maybe.
No.
Blue chickens.
If we have a seaweedy calendar, we have to have a Nerissa chicken, right?
Right?
You can't die with chickens.
Why not?
Can we have chickens in the real world?
Let's not.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Recently... I didn't hear anything.
Have you noticed that maybe there's been some weird tweets in the FUWAMOCO hashtag, Ruffians?
Ruffians!
You aren't up to anything, are you?
Nothing funny, right?
Wow!
Ruffians, there's this tweet that everyone is tweeting and just keeps on repeating.
And it's, Mococo has an innovative solution for keeping her sister out of trouble and out of her way while mining deep underground.
Is this some kind of magic phrase or something?
Is it trendy?
Hi.
But, Moco-chan!
Okay, so if you have an innovative solution, what is this then, huh?
Huh?
What if I don't know?
Keeping your sister out of trouble.
And out of her way?
What's that part about?
Huh?
Who's the one that provides all the food for you at Minecraft, huh?
At real life.
At real life, huh?
Yeah.
I do important stuff.
Ruffians!
What about you?
Little bit of solutions.
I don't know why there's so many people.
Right!
Are they robots?
Even Ruffians are confused.
Murder.
What?
You know.
You plenty solutions?
Tell us then.
Make FUWAMOCO like food.
I've been doing that.
I don't know!
I don't know, Ruffians!
I'm not seeing many answers, but I don't think there's any wrong answers when it comes to innovation, you know?
I guess as long as you're having fun, right?
Right.
Trap Fuwawa.
Let Fuwawa play Kano, please!
What?
It sounded like a ray gun!
It's a Kano ray gun, okay.
Yeah.
But you know, if we know the answer to the innovative solution, then maybe we can get better at Minecraft.
Maybe!
Yeah!
I don't know.
We might not ever find out what resonated about this tweet that makes everyone want to copy it.
Right!
But every time we see it, it always makes us wonder if there are any more innovative solutions out there.
What are we missing?
Right?
There's something amazing waiting and we just don't know.
Mysterious.
BAU BAU!
It's bots.
I don't think that's the answer, Ruffians.
There's something being kept from us.
We just don't know what makes it special yet.
Maybe it's just trendy, is it the cool thing to do?
That's right.
FUWAMOCO, we never know the trends or cool things.
That must be it.
It must be it.
There has to be something.
Secret meaning, huh?
Well, there's been more confusing stuff happening in Hot Muffins!
You may know by now, but recently you know we had an off club with Nerissa and Marine Senchou-senpai, right?
And that was an interesting turn of events.
You know Nerissa, she ran a pool.
And apparently, according to that poll, that poll has the Moco-chan as not sexy.
Ruffians!
Is this the truth?
You know, my Agent Joe-senpai laughed really hard.
She said it so absolutely.
She did.
But I'm not... that sexy.
Really?
Are you using your eyes?
Hi?
Hi!
Are you using them properly?
Hi.
Bibi!
Well...
I have a question for you then.
A couple questions.
Is Korone-senpai not sexy?
Is Luna-senpai not sexy?
Is Noel-senpai not sexy?
Then why am I not sexy then?
Why?
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Maybe you know, so that you can feel better maybe.
Why don't we run a poll to decide the answer that one's for all?
Then you don't need to worry about this!
Don't need to think about it!
A poll, Ruffians!
A poll!
Huh?
Run the pool!
I don't think I'm ready for that.
Not ready yet.
It's scary after the painful pool.
I've already been hurt!
Okay!
Nerissa?
Should I take...
Sexy lessons.
Do it.
From my sexy teacher!
Who's the sexy teacher, Moco-chan?
Ruffians!
I should be my sexy teacher.
Why?!
Nerissa.
You...
What?!
Senso-senpai.
Pero!
Nerissa volunteers!
No, Pero.
I'm ignoring that.
Pero not Nerissa!
Don't ignore Nerissa!
Nerissa!
Nerissa, will you be my sexy teacher?
Oh my gosh, what if she's like, no, I can't because you have no talent, no future, no hope.
She said, I'll do anything for Moco-chan.
You're gonna have your work cut out though, maybe, Nerissa.
BAU BAU!
Do you believe in me, Ruffians?
Might be.
Is it gonna be like the natto challenge, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
I don't need lessons so high.
I don't need lessons though, huh?
I'm already good, huh?
No.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I just gotta remind you.
What?
In case you forgot, we are officially 12 hours away from the newest hololive English generation!
Justices debut!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Going first here on the very left is justice.
It's Justice's leader, Elizabeth Rose Bloodflame.
The leader is on break time!
I almost said Bloodflame.
What?
Say it again.
Elizabeth Rose Budflame.
Maybe that's a bit cruel, I don't know.
Can people say Bloodflame?
She's gonna be my best Budflame.
Bloodflame.
But, you know, I'm a little nervous because
You know, I'm excited also maybe to get to see more of her relaxed sides, you know?
She'll definitely share some of her favorite anime and games with us, right?
Right!
So there's nothing to be scared of.
No.
Right?
Yeah, I'm not scared of the butt flame.
Yeah, we're good puppies.
It's okay.
Yeah.
Nothing to worry about, right?
Okay, Moco-chan.
What do we think Elizabeth's favorite anime is?
I want to say Blood Plus.
Because of the blood flame?
Because of the blood flame!
Blood Plus.
Cold Geass.
That's a good one.
Maybe Cold Geass.
Well, after her, we have Gigi Grumlin!
Justice is Grumlin!
How do you think Gigi's gonna... She's a grumlin, right?
She has to make grumlin noises, right?
Maybe like Gigi Gigi Gigi Gigi?
I feel like that sounds like her laugh.
Gigi Gigi Gigi Gigi!
I don't know, I feel like...
If there's gonna be any funny business, it happens after the debuts.
You know, she's gonna be the one to be the instigator, huh?
You know she's a gremlin after all!
I don't know, what about Gigi's favorite anime though?
Let's forget those things.
Think about the fun, exciting things.
Cold Geass.
Because it starts with a G. I can't say Cold Geass again!
Monogatari, that's a good one!
It doesn't start with a G, okay!
There's a G in it, that's okay.
Guilty Gear!
That's not an anime.
That's a game, but yes.
A Blazblue?
Yeah, that too!
Yeah, everybody likes Cold Geass!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO
FUWAMOCO You know, we'll definitely find out a lot more on what exactly Justice is very soon!
Ruffians!
We get to do that all together!
Because Advent, we're gonna be doing a watch-along of Justice's debuts on both day 1 and day 2!
Off-colab!
BAU BAU!
Please join us and all of us for an amazingly fun time over the weekend, okay?
You can check it out over on the official hololive English YouTube channel, okay?
BAU BAU!
It's another FUWAMOCO Morning.
That means we have a doggy of a day today, right?
Today's doggy of a day is... De-den!
Skylar looks a little bit perplexed.
How does Skylar BAU BAU Moco-chan?
Very excited in the kitty pool.
Doggy pool now.
Squirtle is super cute!
I'm ready for summer when I look at this picture of Skylar.
Maybe she can be our pool buddy this summer.
Maybe this time we'll actually go swimming.
As long as Skylar's there with us, right?
Then we won't be so alone.
We can't go swimming with Pero.
But Skylar, BAU BAU!
And next, Ruffians, it's not just Skylar that's been going for runs, right?
You've been going for walks too, right?
Let's take a look at our Today I Went On A Walk!
We have De-den!
Another really cooling picture!
So beautiful!
We hope that you're able to stay out of the sun rays.
It does look hot, huh?
Right!
Yeah, make sure, Ruffians, that you don't forget your sunscreen, okay?
I know it can be sticky and like... No, I don't want sunscreen.
Sunscreen!
Make sure you put it on, okay?
It's very important.
Yeah.
The buildings have deadly lasers!
Think of that and then apply the sunscreen, okay?
Ruffians!
Which one of you are guilty of not putting on sunscreen?
Raise your paws.
Ruffians!
You!
Why do I see so many me's and no not me's?
Huh?
No, if you stay inside, you still need sunscreen, okay?
Yeah!
Unless you don't have any windows or any natural light sources or... Maybe it's okay.
But if you have a window!
Yeah!
Okay!
You need to put on sunscreen, okay?
Yeah!
And if you think... If you think, oh well, I don't like sunscreen... That's because you haven't found the right sunscreen yet!
That's the wrong one!
Yeah!
Okay.
Even if you don't learn, it's important.
Wear the sunscreen.
Got it.
Well, there was a question here.
Are FUWAMOCO afraid of water?
We're not the best with water.
We can swim, you know, but we're demon dogs.
Demon dogs, we don't.
You know, it's fun, but we don't really like jumping in, or deep water, and then we become all soggy.
I can doggy paddle!
Yeah, I'm confident in my doggy paddle.
Not the deep diving.
We'll leave the more aquatic stuffs to normal dogs.
You know, Gura-senpai.
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
And today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
This is a question for us to ask when you arrive in Japan.
Oh, it's gone past a bit.
A little bit of an oldie question, but a good question!
FUWAMOCO, what was the first thing you ate after arriving in Japan?
I think we talked about this once.
Very delicious!
The first thing we ate.
What is a salad bag?
A bag of just sliced cabbage.
It's good because what you do is you just open the bag.
And then you put in your salad dressing.
And then you take your chopsticks and you mix it all up.
But then we had a pondering!
We had a pondering after, so... So it's not that sad, right?
It's kind of like you can just imagine the pondering was first, right?
Right!
Yeah.
Nattou wa... What about the nattou?
Nattou can wait.
Nattou wa atokara.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Remember Ruffians, if you go on a walk and you see something... Oh!
That's kinda cool!
I see FUWAMOCO like this, or... Oh!
I think FUWAMOCO wouldn't like this!
Share it with us, okay?
If you think they wouldn't like it, I don't know, you never learn.
Or if you happen to see Perroccino, something that we're not gonna like.
Share that with us.
Or if you see a cute dog... Share it with us!
I wanted to become the Doggie of the Day!
We saw a cute dog.
Right, Moco-chan?
I got scared.
But please let us know with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And we have another stream coming up.
Very soon after this one.
We have...
Keep talking and nobody explodes!
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be a little bit messy, right?
Yeah, but we played this a little while ago.
I've completely forgotten how to stop the bombs.
But I'm gonna help Moco-chan!
I'm gonna give the instructions and we'll see just how good of a team we are because twins are always a good team, right?
We're a very good team, huh?
Yeah, we're gonna show our teamwork.
Yeah!
Please join us, okay, Ruffians?
And then very shortly after that, our new kouhai, Justice, will be making their debuts!
BAU BAU!
Maybe let's take a quick peek at the schedule.
While our kohai make their debuts, we're gonna be watching over them!
Yeah!
All together with Advent, cause we're doing a watch-along!
And it will be on the hololive English official channel.
Like I mentioned.
And then, after Justice finishes all the debuts, then FUWAMOCO, you know, we thought that maybe we'd chat all together.
Play some Suika game time a bit!
And I know we had it scheduled for...
1130 PM PT.
But it might be a bit later.
Might be a bit later.
We will be back as fast as we can, okay?
We're gonna run, Ruffians.
Okay.
How about Batsu game?
Huh?
What do you mean we have to play Suika game with the punishment, huh?
What if the punishment is that we buy a bunch of the fruits and then we have to eat them?
Is that a punishment?
I don't like fruit.
And then, FUWAMOCO, we're gonna do our best on Sunday because that's a big homework day for us.
Wish us luck, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians who are joining us to the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU debuts!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
And for waking up early to be able to share your morning with us every day this week!
It's a big day!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Overlord Chino!
BAU BAU!
Fuji!
Demon Eye!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's too fast.
Advent!
BAU BAU!
Kikito!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!